hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to tiny box Tim or what the
hell oh my god the bottoms of objects I
don't know hey grump out an alarm is
very tannic for a second there do I need
to be scared already
okay anyway this is a fan-made game
about tiny box Tim and it actually
represents a level from a late night
drink which if you haven't seen it's one
of my favorite cam needs to cut some
stories of all time and it's the origin
story of tiny box Tim so let's get into
it also Oh oh my god oh another gorgeous
day I can't do the tiny box Tim voice
for a long period of time what should i
do today cuz it's just annoying it's
like nails on a chalkboard oh I know
I'll go on an adventure that'll be fun
onwards oh my god it's dynamite sim oh
my god lose my mind such a comfortable
bed ah he's so cute look at him look at
him if you're not looking at him what
are you looking at stop browsing the
internet pay attention to this game
because it's too cute okay anyway let's
carry on
I imagine this representing like the
level in amnesia it's a lantern the
owner never uses it though I wonder if
somebody will ever take it for their own
use Oh tiny box Tim I wonder indeed it's
so amazing because he's gonna meet me
nothing like that's the most amazing
thing in the world one night I heard
some people walking and talking down the
main hallway
I couldn't hear everything they were
saying to one another all I could
comprehend was a male voice saying I'll
do it anywhere what about you followed
by a female voice responding I don't
mind we are alone in this house aren't
we
after a short silence a man and woman
looked into this room and looked around
the man eagerly said good enough and
they started removing each others
clothes Tim how did you look at knives
and think about that they obviously
weren't paying attention because then
the man picked the woman up and sat on
this table the woman gave a loud yell
and darting oh okay down the hall the
man was close by I'm sorry I didn't see
the daggers I fell
shortly after that but when I woke up I
noticed blood on the wanton of daggers
and drips lady got the door I think
those two learned a valuable lesson that
day yes beware or you will become your
own butt stabber what kind of story is
that Tim you should never have a naked
wrestling match in a room filled with
all sorts of okay oh that's one shiny or
but I've never seen it before the owner
must have got it recently got it there
are cracks along the side that look
really deep it might have been dropped
some here wait why did it get all cloudy
on the inside maybe I should go
adventuring somewhere else
okay blue is my favorite color his heavy
armor fell over on somebody's foot once
it was like seeing a cannonball crush a
can of tomato soup oh if that tomato
soup had chunks of bone makes Tim oh my
goodness you have weird thoughts Tim
anyway I'm sure that guy is fine lose my
favorite color
wait I'm always admiring this collection
of weapons and armor everything is so
shiny and well-kept okay I'm gonna move
on now Tim Oh someone had fun writing
this story but it's still adorable so I
guess it's good sometimes I hear people
playing this piano I wish my noodle arms
were strong enough to play it properly
hmm I wonder if I could
beautiful halt that's adorable Jenny oh
man Oh Oh that's actually good Wow I
thought it was just gonna be man like
random smashing of his box body on the
keys all right Tim that's enough we got
to move on
we got an adventure okay Wow didn't know
I had it in me Tim you're so talented I
always loved the smell of tea
what are you British I didn't know tiny
box Tim was British I don't know about
this origin story okay I think that's
enough exploring I need to find like
what I'm actually supposed to do before
things get even weirder all right hmm I
can only reach the first shelf I know at
some point he's got to meet some bigger
boxes and they're gonna beat him up hmm
who left an open bottle of glass wine
sitting on the table I would try
something but I can't quite reach I'm
just a tiny box after all just some
bottles of wine okay what we got here oh
it's another orb oh it's a savvy orb oh
that makes a lot more sense okay I
understand now also I finally figured
out how to turn the air conditioner on
this room it was really hot the faster
your recordings I know you probably guys
probably see me sweating all right they
look like they're holding hands
aw but they're inanimate objects stop
bomb how do I turn you off okay there we
go I think I think I'm good to finish
the rest of this recording without a
bomb going off randomly it's this this
alarm clock that they have on the
counter over there nothing that you guys
need to worry about really wait what
okay I kind of went sideways into this
room ahh Oh glory my favorite I did not
know that tiny box Tim liked tea this
much I didn't know a lot of things about
him I guess I never really spoke to him
about what he likes I mostly just adored
him and hugged him and loved him thought
I knew him all right whoa hello it's
dark in the wall something chill where
is where is she I don't know what you're
talking about I'm sorry find her now
okay
can you tell me a name oh okay then all
right tiny box Tim looks come on you
didn't bring her you lied you just died
that's not okay you can't just kill Tim
oh good thing I saved I guess oh I
didn't know that this is gonna be like
this what's with the doll there's a lot
more to this game than I thought yeah as
soon as I get close the face goes weird
G yeah I know I know I know okay I'm out
I'm out I'm out I'll go find her it's
locked there's got to be a key around
here somewhere you're right Tim they're
usually in is in these stories I did not
know that Tim was gonna like have his
own little adventure here like I thought
it was just gonna be the story of how we
met me but we always already know that
story so we don't actually need to
explore it I guess all right so there's
glasses of wine strewn about there's a
Bible here is another glass right here
Oh I'll drink some I'm sure nobody would
mind if I take a sip tiny box Tim how
old are you kind of gross I don't see
why people like this stuff so much okay
I'm starting to feel sick uh-oh maybe I
shouldn't drink random one
Oh No look his face oh he's sick he's
got an upset tongue Tom little Tim Tim
got a bad tum tum hmm I wish I could hug
him and hold him I don't have my tiny
box Tim plushies here oh I don't know
it's weird I can see the reply get whoa
where did those suits of armor come from
what's going on oh I really shouldn't
have drank that wine whoa something
changed okay what is that yes I'll save
what are these why does it seem like
these statues are staring at me you're
not gonna question why they totally
changed into something whoo ah can I
push one of these no but I can push this
probably
there we go there we go this this
adventure is like way more involved than
I thought it would be okay what did that
do I don't necessary know oh okay
isn't this room I was just in how did it
end up like this good question I don't
know these things
this glowing crystal is floating above a
circle of light however it is not the
source of the crystals dim glow upon
further inspection you realize that
there is a ball of light producing a
faint glow in the center of the crystal
touch the crystal sure why not whoa whoa
it's a teleportation crystal that's good
right
I think gargoyles are staring at me not
like those other ones were that's for
damn sure
okay so this led me over here but I
don't know what I'm supposed to do here
just yet I've got a oh no he's got a
worried expression it's gonna be okay
it's gonna be okay oh okay there's a
puzzle here god this is so involved I'm
not trying to be insulting about other
fan games that were made in the past for
me but it's just like I didn't know like
I had no idea like this one was gonna be
particularly involved it's so cool
though look I love it like tiny bucks
tim has his own official game all about
him and his adventures before he met me
well Gary an adventurer before he met me
no it's okay I guess okay so what was
the point of coming over here nothing
there was no point so I gotta find a way
to solve this puzzle but I'm probably
just gonna assume that there's like some
way that it can tell me what it's
supposed to do
cuz I'm assuming that has to do with
putting these in a certain order and
then doing something I don't necessarily
know I'm kind of just oh I got it I
guess wow I thought that was gonna need
to be a specific order but there we go
then I was just stalling for time I was
just bullshitting which is what I do for
most of my life but here we go what's
this doing in the middle of nowhere
picked up a silver key I thought that
was a letter but I guess I was wrong
there there anything else over here no I
don't think so so I can go back I have
the silver key now which means I can
open the door if that door is still
gonna be the same as it was before I
don't necessarily know that but Tim
still looks worried so God he should not
have drank that wine why did they need
to go into another world to be able to
pick up a key it's not fair for little
Tim Tim he's just a little timid guy he
doesn't need to be distraught in such a
way hey this suit of armor looks extra
shiny it easy enough to glowing dots
where the everything's gonna be okay
little buddy
my little biscuits gonna get out of here
alive nah man is I think you're worrying
me because I know these grumps are gonna
come into the office any moment now it's
like in the morning and they're whoa
well that was weird okay I don't think
that these rooms have changed at all
so now I can go unlock the door I
believe anyway so I should be able to go
unlock this door silver key unlocks it
it worked yes it did you're such a
little smarty little Tim Tim there's a
broom in the corner as a clock ah
there's a letter here an envelope an
envelope it feels like something's
inside hey yoki found a key also note
the door is hidden in a room filled with
darkness to reveal the door simply walk
up to it the key will know what to do
the key will know what to do I guess
I'll find out what that's supposed to
mean soon enough okay then so I got to
find a room full of darkness this smell
is making me want some tea
all right you and your tea obsession
it's a little unhealthy but I'll let you
be consider here in the land of
nightmares and I can't really help you
so the doll is still in that other room
and I I she wants me to find
quote-unquote her I don't know who she
is maybe she is this dress
I'm full of darkness would it be in the
closet no I'm kind of reaching here
I'm also stalling again like I don't
necessarily know what it wants from me
but I'm well alright then I don't think
that there was any other place here that
could be misconstrued as a room of
darkness so I'm guessing that there has
to be something in the other area that I
I missed or overlooked so I'm gonna go
back over there and just explore some
more with the do a little dim dim but I
don't think that there was anything else
down this way like it was just a series
of these rather creepy looking statues
I'm hoping that one of them isn't gonna
come after me but I don't think that
there would have been anything else all
the way down here it was just a long
hallway and nothing right or at least
that's Mike oh oh there was something I
did not notice this at all there's a
creepy teddy bear I'm just assuming it's
a creepy teddy bear maybe a perfectly
nice teddy bear but whatever teddy bears
just staring at the wall yep it's a
creepy teddy bear oh are those the big
boxes
oh those the big boxes that are gonna
bully me no it's gonna be okay Tim Tim
it's gonna be okay okay what is all this
I'm assuming like I don't really
remember the layout of the amnesia
mansion when I was playing a late-night
drink so I'm assuming that a lot of this
is emulating the areas in that place
where am i oh there I am okay so I I
don't know if I'm forgetting something
uh no hope no hope no hope no hope no
hope no hope no no hope none well that
was informative and I feel much better
about my life now that I read that note
well let's just move on and find a room
of darkness maybe it's gonna be over
here Tim really shouldn't the drank in
that wine drunk drank drinking drink did
more wine or is that blood fountain I
don't think I want to splash around in
there anymore anymore when did you do it
before man this place is huge
like I really didn't know that this game
was gonna be this involved I shouldn't
leave no matter how scared I am I'll
leave soon enough as soon as a big
strapping man comes finds me and takes
me on an adventure oh I want to go on an
adventure so badly I mean technically
I'm going on an adventure I didn't see
that I think I can get to that oh yeah
here we go okay so what is this what's
this letter doing here left right right
left this is supposed to mean
okay left right right left so they're
most like I'm assuming that refers to
the switches up in the area that I did
before to get to the other place so if I
do that combination will probably be
leading to something different than what
it did before with just all the rights
so left right right left was that it
left right right left it's probably in
my inventory so I'm gonna jet up there
and try to see if there's something else
that I can find wait was there something
wolves over here basically this lock
there should be a key but I mean to have
a key could I use the key or do I have
to go over there and find something else
and try to come back later
I was this hallway wasn't so long cuz
then I wouldn't have to go back and
forth so many times all right you just
get that we try the new combination that
I have such that it maybe I will be back
so you don't have to see this left right
right left
Oh oh-ho what did that do what did it do
what do you can't just do something and
not show me what it did I need to know I
got a no man I got a no now ah maybe it
changed because it was that other area
in the intermediate stages of
teleporting in the crystal in the last
area and there were two gargoyles
standing there so there might have been
something changed over there I mean ooh
he's happy again
oh the drug trip is over all the
nightmares are gonna go away little dim
dim probably not prob probably not okay
no no that's not the case oh whoa
he flew at him yeah
well I don't know if that's what I just
did but holy crap look at that I did Oh
are those big boxes that big box berry
big boxes of bully berry oh hi
he took me away from her and brought me
here I need to be with her can you take
me to her yeah it's please don't yell at
me like okay come with me
all right I'll just be on my way
you weren't there before were you you
were not also there don't even think
about it don't even think about it ha ha
ha hey statues I don't care if it's like
a 16-bit game I hate statues this is
made in an RPG maker for those that
didn't know I mean I played a great
number of RPG Maker games before but oh
my god this is so adorable oh man I
don't know how long this game is or
otherwise I would like I might know I'm
gonna play it all I want this game to be
all in one just because this is adorable
I don't think it's that long so probably
won't be that bad little dolly
you brought her didn't you I can I can
feel her presence
everybody okay here here take this I got
the basement key now go go never come
back you dolls need to relax a bit
drink some Earl Grey tea or is Earl Grey
a stimulant I don't know
one of them has caffeine in it I think
Earl Grey does then again I don't know
my teas I'm a coffee drinking American
little distracted you can't beat me I'm
America tiny buxom ain't gonna take no
[ __ ] from you guys you do adorable look
how happy and you can't catch me
i knowwe know how I don't know why the
face isn't changing to the happy face
because Donny but sim is so happy right
now he's just a happy-go-lucky guy who
shouldn't have done anything that he did
anyway okay so wait who's there hell are
you who the hell do you think you are
yeah was he
I am the landlord of this house well
what do you want I see you found your
way through my little puzzle puzzle
you're the one who put the keys and
notes throughout the house why simply to
pie time you see today is a day you are
destined to be found but it has to
happen at the right time when you made
the decision to go on an adventure glug
glug I knew you would end up being in
the wrong place at the wrong time I had
to keep you away from the basement for
as long as I could it was the only way
to ensure your fate my fate what are you
talking about why are you telling me
this dot dot dot
it's almost time he will find you
he will take care of you he will love
you have a good life tiny box Tim that
doesn't make any sense his plot holes in
all of that plan old care wait dot dot
dot I guess I should find out what he
means I guess you should Tim I guess you
should oh my gosh that is an emulation I
know I know that area I remember that
very distinctly because I remember it
because I played him I found him right
there come with me on an adventure tiny
box Tim maybe I got to smash you open in
the keys inside you know it's turned
enough so weird cuz I didn't know what
the hell is going on with tiny box him
but oh my goodness it was cute and
adorable and very well made
shut up me thank you guys so much for
watching this was an amazing adventure I
really do appreciate it too the creators
of this game alchemists who made custom
music for it apparently and work really
hard on it thank you so much for making
it for me thank you all so much for
watching check out the other fan-made
games that have been made for me there's
been a ton and I back
got a few more than I need to get
through before I get through them all
and there's gonna be some more made I
imagine but just thank you guys so much
for dedicating your time to make games
for me there are a lot of fun especially
things like this that are like really
cute and adorable and important to me so
thanks again everybody for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye
oh one more thing I guess this is a
guy's channel let me just flip through
to make sure there's absolutely nothing
left nope that's it okay I'm gonna call
you tiny box Tim you're gonna come with
me on an adventure tiny box Tim